how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and
marvel cinematic universe we've gotten a
lot of information about wanda
vision lately including yesterday a
whole entire article from entertainment
weekly
about the show that gave us some pretty
good reveals and pretty good insight on
the show i'll link that up above
but one thing that we haven't gotten yet
is the official release date for the
show now it's been said that it's
supposed to be released
in 2020 this year but lately there's
been a rumor going around stating that
it's actually going to be released in
2021
well i'm here to set the record straight
the best that i can as we got some news
this morning about the release date and
we also got some news about the entire
marvel disney plus show production
schedule that is planned for all of
these marvel disney plus series
we're talking miss marvel hawkeye
she-hulk and moon knight so i'll break
it all down in this video but first if
you're new be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest mcu
news and you don't miss out on my
giveaway i'm teaming
up with heroeshideout.com and giving
away a lot of marvel merch including
funko pops and marvel legends items just
subscribe like the video leave a comment
down below for your chance to enter
so first and foremost let me explain
that the rumor for wanda and vision
being released in 2021
isn't really that solid it came from
somebody talking to a disney plus
customer service representative in a
chat room on their computer
the fan asked about the one division
release date and the customer service
representative said that it's coming in
2021
but we as fans have seen this happen
within our community plenty of times
and they've been wrong plenty of times
because let's face it
customer service representatives for
disney plus aren't being told the
release dates for these major studio
disney plus shows that are coming up
they just don't know that information
so this rumor shouldn't be taken
seriously however this morning
entertainment tonight a very huge media
company and
network did shine some light on the one
division release date they did say that
it is indeed confirmed to be coming out
in 2020
eyeing a december release date now it's
widely speculated right now that we're
most likely going to get this on
december 18th
or on december 25th which is christmas
day but if marvel studios and disney are
trying to wait until the mandalorian
season 2 finishes
that means we're more than likely going
to get it on christmas day
as the mandalorian finishes its last
episode on the 18th so the 18th and the
25th
of december are our two best guesses
right now but the good news is that
entertainment tonight did confirm that
it is coming in 2020. so no need to
worry about those 2021 rumors
now as far as the rest of the marvel
studios disney plus shows go
things are well underway loki is filming
right now in fact it's filming in the
same studio and
lot that spider-man 3 is filming at in
fact the building that they're filming
in
is right next to the spider-man 3
building now i'm not suggesting there's
going to be any crossovers here however
i think that would be absolutely epic if
loki somehow managed to find his way
into the spider-man universe but again
that's just wishful thinking not me
actually suggesting it now the
production for miss marvel has started
it is filming
now we have our miss marvel we have our
directors we have our writers
everything is underway for miss marvel
so it should be ready to go by late 2021
but most likely early 2022 to be safe
then we have hawkeye now the original
plan for the hawkeye series was to begin
filming in april of 2020 but obviously
due to the pandemic
that didn't work out but right now it is
planned to start filming in december of
this year
then we have the she-hulk series now it
appears that we have our she-hulk
tatiana messlani
was reported to be our new she-hulk
however when she was asked about the
role she denied it
however there are plenty of instances in
the past where marvel actors have denied
roles only to end up playing them so i'm
guessing that she actually has landed
the role of jennifer walters she-hulk
but she-hulk is going to start filming
in february of 2021 which means it
should be ready by spring of 2022
and then we have moon knight which is
most likely going to be right there with
she-hulk now we have our director and
our writers for moon knight and it has
been said that oscar isaac
is going to be our moon knight although
the reports do say that he is in
negotiations right now and the final
paperwork is not signed but marvel
studios
wants him so this is going to be right
along with she-hulk most likely starting
production in february of 2021
and be ready by late spring of 2022. so
as of right now that is the production
schedule for the disney plus shows that
are not already completed or have not
already begun filming and this isn't
even
including the mcu movies that are coming
so although this year was kind of a
bummer we have a lot to look forward to
in the marvel cinematic universe so be
sure to subscribe so you don't miss out
on any of the latest
mcn news and in the comments down below
let me know which project
you're most excited about in marvel's
phase four let me know what you think in
the comments down below don't forget to
like the video and subscribe so you can
enter my giveaway where i'm partnered
with heroeshideout.com
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof